[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace 5 años por esta época más o menos
en navidad estaba en san antonio texas
pasando con mi familia y creo que cometí
uno de los peores errores de mi vida o
en ese momento lo creí le regalé a mi
mamá un iphone de navidad
cuando uno le regala a las mamás
tecnología pues con el regalo tiene que
venir pues la enseñanza de cómo se usa
el aparato que uno le regalo
y en el caso de mi mamá y el iphone pues
vino bajar facebook y whatsapp que son
las dos aplicaciones que mi mamá más usa
mi mamá que era una persona que yo
pensaba que no era muy buena con la
tecnología empezó a ser la persona que
me escribía más mensajes por whatsapp al
día
me saludaba a las siete y media de la
mañana y si yo no le respondía al
segundo ella me preguntaba que por qué
no le respondía
entonces yo y si yo no le respondía a
ese mensaje al segundo d porque yo no le
respondía el mensaje ella me decía que
si yo estaba brava con ella
y yo no mamá yo no estoy graba contigo
lo que pasa es que no estoy todo el día
pegada del celular esperando a que tú me
mandes un mensaje que yo te tenga que
responder inmediatamente
pero no solo es mi mamá se convirtió en
la persona que más cadenas de whatsapp
me mandaba
me imagino y sus días y los abuelos pero
mi mamá les les prometo que era la que
más cadenas de whatsapp mandaban
y la mayoría de las cadenas de whatsapp
que mi mamá me mandaba eran noticias
falsas
y yo soy periodista trabajo en dar yo
información y en dar información veraz
para que la gente está informada
entonces le preguntaba a mi mamá mamá de
dónde sacaste esa información porque
crees que esa noticia es real y ella me
decía porque me la mandó mi amiga
patricia por whatsapp
o me decía vi esta noticia en facebook o
encontré esta noticia en internet
encontrar la información para mi mamá en
whatsapp en facebook o en internet era
suficiente para ella para ella decir que
esa información era real
y que era una noticia verdadera
en américa latina en promedio
los ciudadanos nos estamos pasando en
internet 37 horas a la semana eso en
promedio son 5 horas al día
conectados a internet a través de un
celular oa través de un computador sin
embargo las horas aumentan para los
millennials esta es el número de horas
que yo me la paso en mi celular al día
en promedio 5 horas 22 minutos los
millenials en promedio se están pasando
en frente de un celular o de un
computador 40 horas a la semana
hoy más que nunca estamos conectados a
internet y tenemos acceso a mucha
información a noticias del mundo entero
y es maravilloso pero también estamos
conectados a la mayor cantidad de
desinformación que hemos encontrado
nunca
internet es una plataforma maravillosa
pero ayuda a manipular
y ayuda a manipular a la gente porque
nos estamos informando a través de
internet
y no se trata del nivel educativo de las
personas si usted es más educado no
significa que va a compartir menos
noticias falsas si usted es menos menos
educado no significa que va a compartir
más noticias falsas acuérdense ustedes
que el presidente uribe compartió una
noticia falsa o ha compartido muchas
hubo una en particular cuando se firmó
el proceso de paz en donde compartió una
portada falsa del 'daily news' que decía
que
el estado colombiano le había regalado
el estado en el país a las farc
obviamente será una noticia
evidentemente falsa pero no solo el
expresidente uribe también el ex alcalde
de bogotá gustavo fecha que también ha
compartido noticias falsas a través de
internet como por ejemplo cuando
compartió un vídeo en ese momento del
candidato iván duque que estaba editado
o cuando compartió una foto del
presidente iván duque que era
evidentemente un montaje leyendo un
libro al revés
entonces si nuestros líderes políticos
si los líderes de opinión están
compartiendo información falsa que
iremos nosotros porque no vamos a
compartir información falsa porque mi
mamá no va a enviarme una cadena a
whatsapp que no es verdad
pero porque nosotros hacemos eso es
porque compartimos información que no es
real
porque las personas que crean las
noticias falsas apelan a una herramienta
muy poderosa que son nuestros
sentimientos
y una vez se apela a los sentimientos se
pierde completamente la razón y la gente
que escribe que crea esta desinformación
apela a dos sentimientos muy importantes
que son el miedo y la rabia
a penas si usted siente miedo y rabia
cuando lee algo inmediatamente quiere
compartirlo porque ya la razón se fue
porque usted inmediatamente quiere
mostrarle a sus amigos a su familia lo
que le produjo rabia lo que le produjo
un miedo
el estudio más importante que se ha
hecho de desinformación en los eeuu lo
hizo la universidad de maine y descubrió
que una noticia falsa tiene un 70% más
de probabilidad de ser compartida que
una noticia que es real 70%
y por qué
porque la verdad es aburrida las
noticias falsas tienen unos titulares
rimbombantes que dan ganas de compartir
por eso cuando usted ve a un titular que
le parece demasiado estrambótico
sospechas porque puede ser una noticia
falsa
ese mismo estudio de la universidad de
michael se dio cuenta que desde el 2006
hasta el 2016 los votos que son estos
mecanismos que se utilizan en internet
para volver viral la información
compartieron la misma cantidad de
noticias falsas que de noticias
verdaderas
entonces no eran los bots ni los
mecanismos digitales los que estaban
finalizando la información falsa era
culpa de ellos entonces de quién es la
culpa tiene estado realizando
información que no es real
nosotros los seres humanos somos
nosotros los que estamos desinformados
somos nosotros los que estamos
compartiendo información que no es real
y eso porque hace daño porque no debería
porque nos deberíamos preocupar
porque los seres humanos tomamos
decisiones basados en los hechos y
basados en la información que
recolectamos
y si recolectamos información falsa
información que no es real pues
terminamos tomando malas decisiones
pero además podemos terminar dañando a
través de una cadena de whatsapp que es
falsa una persona que podría ser usted
podría ser su mamá podría ser su hermana
podemos terminar dañando una marca que
se demoró años en construirse podemos
terminar dañando una institución
o incluso terminar dañando un país
porque las noticias falsas que más se
realizan a pesar de que todas se
finalizan las que más se realizan son
las noticias políticas
y si usted comparte noticias políticas
falsas está haciendo que las personas
tomen decisiones equivocadas en el
futuro
pero quizá lo más peligroso de compartir
noticias que no sean ciertas
es que están matando gente
en agosto de este año en mexico dos
personas fueron quemadas vivas por una
cadena de whatsapp era falsa
la gente en méxico los mató eran su tío
un tío y un sobrino los quemaron vivos
porque pensaron que eran los
responsables de haber robado y extirpado
los órganos de los niños y era una
cadena de whatsapp que era mentira pero
eso no pasa sólo en méxico
en colombia
en octubre en bogotá en la localidad de
ciudad bolívar a un hombre que trabajaba
en construcción que tenía 23 años con
dos hijos lo mataron y lo mató
a los golpes de 150 personas que
pensaron y creyeron por una cadena de
whatsapp que ese señor era el violador
de los niños cadena de whatsapp era
falsa también lo confirmó la policía
pero la policía también confirmó que
había descubierto seis cadenas de
whatsapp similares que también eran
falsas
y en la india
en julio de este año según los medios de
comunicación 12 personas fueron
asesinadas por cuentas décadas por
cuenta de cadenas de whatsapp que eran
falsas
así que la invitación que yo les quiero
hacer hoy aquí
es a que piensen que ustedes son
productores de información así como
consumimos información también
producimos información somos lo que se
denomina producirse
y ser productor de información trae una
gran responsabilidad porque porque somos
muy poderosos acuérdense lo que decía
spider-man con un gran poder en una gran
responsabilidad
por eso hoy los quiero invitar a que la
próxima vez que reciban una cadena de
whatsapp que vean una noticia en
facebook o que lean una noticia en
internet cumplan tres pasos básicos que
pueden parecer obvios pero a pesar de lo
vil de lo obvio
no los estamos haciendo regularmente
primero
no comparta algo inmediatamente apenas
le llegue la información no lo comparta
segundo
investigue la fuente de información haga
su tarea mire quién le manda la noticia
cuál es el medio de comunicación que lo
publica aparecen más de un medio de
comunicación quién es el autor
y tercero mire la fecha fíjese en la
fecha de la publicación porque una
noticia puede haber sido real hace cinco
años pero si usted la lee hoy está
completamente descontextualizada y
termina siendo falsa
y todos ustedes
tienen un poder enorme en sus bolsillos
y en este momento en sus manos levanten
los celulares los que tienen un celular
inteligente acá todo el porque los veo a
todos tomando fotos y chateando
esa herramienta es muy poderosa ustedes
tienen un poder enorme en sus manos y
por eso lo que les quiero dejar yo hoy
aquí
[Música]
es que cuando reciban información
respiren piensen y ahí sí compartan pero
recuerden también que se o vale no
compartir y guardar su celular en el
bolsillo gracias
[Aplausos]